parla ro le ha bisogno di un italiano continua a
correre pigro Purkinje tato minuti la mia
lingua a Kuala me pesos premarin Emilio
Elvan sapere da ha fatto Mila Dodi
più economico di me Erin
no ridere Emily ha bisogno di ome Sun Fanta
una nuova Delta comitato in realtà
farà un  canta solo Chi aspetta aspetta aspetta zero
nessun cambiamento nelle nostre menti ma si
riflette anche nel sistema della moda questo è
la demanda kami quindi non manca nessuno que
esto prima di questo e nella sua Erica
scusa appartamento Sione sei pronto per il
cambiamento è il mio altro  la domanda è che la moda
va dal passato presente al futuro
è fottutamente moda che guarda al futuro
che torna indietro è questo il cambiamento che stiamo
aspettando ed è questo il cambiamento per cui
siamo pronti nelle nostre menti e in
ogni momento di transizione sentiamo
la pressione dell'apocalisse prima  la
fine dei tempi andiamo alle basi andiamo
alle quattro diverse skin e chiediamoci
chi siamo veramente oggi la
prima pelle è il nostro corpo il supporto per la
moda e qui vedete l'esterno  allo
scheletro su un corpo finto la seconda pelle
è la nostra identità perché attraverso la moda
ci esprimiamo possiamo nasconderci
possiamo mostrarci possiamo fare
un gioco quindi la moda ha questo tipo di
facilità da nascondere o meno nella terza
pelle è il posto in cui ci  vivi in
è una città o l'ambiente che
influenza il nostro corpo e qui abbiamo
Firenze che guarda in alto le persone guardano
magari aggiungi un nuovo grattacielo un nuovo tipo di
Firenze in
futuro il prepuzio è la nostra tecnologia che
usiamo ogni giorno ogni ora ogni notte
e ovviamente  Internet è il modo in cui siamo
informati e soprattutto nella moda
sappiamo tutto per tutti ogni
minuto e abbiamo anche 6/10
dell'istinto stiamo diventando sciamani stiamo
perdendo il nostro istinto o
stiamo diventando sciamani forse saremo
corpi galleggianti in  il prossimo futuro e
anche questa è la fine dell'inizio
Sento che tutti stiamo attraversando una
metamorfosi
siamo cambiati enormemente nei cinque
sei sette dieci anni non siamo le stesse
persone e  più siamo animali con una
sorta di istinto primitivo che usano
tecnologie avanzate guarda l'agenda
e guarda la femminilità del
Botticelli e la mascolinità ma guarda
anche i cappotti della collezione Tom Brown
siamo femminili i cappotti sono usati
su un corpo maschile  guarda il corpo
tatuato o il corpo vuoto sono le stesse
persone ma lui sembra diverso è la
stessa anima è lo stesso istinto ma
ci viene più come un istinto primitivo
questa metamorfosi significa passare da
un'apocalisse di coppia al paradiso e
questo è  la mia domanda se guardando qui
dalla finestra a Palazzo Vecchio sarà
questo,
siamo pronti per andare in paradiso, quindi l'
apocalisse è usata davvero rappresentata come
la fine, ma penso che comunque
significhi intrinsecamente rivelazione, quindi il tempo
è circolare e ogni fine è  un
inizio ogni minaccia e opportunità
e stiamo vivendo così velocemente il tempo non è
più lo stesso di cinque anni fa
viviamo ogni minuto ogni ora in modo molto
intenso e  vedi che ho solo
dieci minuti per dire quello che sento che
sarà la moda è un dovere
pensare a cosa sta finendo l'inizio per non
recitare quindi qui ho chiesto alle persone
quando sono venute a Firenze perché sono
di moda  e Steven Segal ha detto perché
cambiare il mondo non è un'opzione
è un obbligo almeno possiamo provare tutta la
moda è la strada verso il futuro e
penso che la moda abbia quella connotazione in cui
possiamo pensare liberamente e realizzare liberamente l'
indumento e goderci le persone che  stiamo costruendo
ponti dentro e fuori abbiamo la
mente e lo spazio stiamo costruendo ponti
tra la natura e la tecnologia e
anche tra le nostre diverse skin quindi
eccoci allora cos'è un'entità ID reale qual
è la nostra entità ID forse abbiamo
identità diverse il primo  uno è Amleto essere
o non essere il secondo è Damien
Hirst comprare o non comprare
si tratta di lusso il terzo è Givenchy
è lo stilista essere designer o
no ci poniamo molte domande a
riguardo e il  l'ultimo è Rick
Janet che ha colpito il corpo tatuato perché
stava cambiando l'identità opportunità o
calpestare la moda è un mostro è un
mostro con due teste parliamo di
fast fast fashion e industrial
luxury ovviamente la moda è fuori uso molti
libri sono stati scritti di recente per  diciamo che l'
interruzione come principio dobbiamo
pensare al futuro quindi va bene
ripristiniamo la moda è organizzata da calendari
e stagioni quindi se i Maya dicono che
dobbiamo vivere senza di loro questo potrebbe essere
un segno, penso che potremmo creare
sistemi di moda?  sei nostalgico e
futuristico si stanno unendo,
pensa al
mondo senza stagioni e
calendari della moda puoi immaginare quanto
sarebbe fantastico puoi immaginare quante
settimane della moda ci sono nel mondo in
Africa Amsterdam Australia Canada
Copenaghen Los Angeles Mumbai Rio de
Janeiro e così via  si tratta di
abbigliamento maschile abbigliamento donna abbigliamento per bambini
accessori e tutte quelle persone che
vanno e vengono
è come se migliaia di moda fallissero
La settimana della moda è ora nel mondo dove gli
acquirenti se non abbiamo più quegli acquirenti
della settimana della moda
possono acquistare quando hanno fame di
nuovi capi gli scrittori possono scrivere quando
vogliono scrivere qualcosa questo potrebbe essere un
mondo completamente nuovo dovremmo essere tutti
vestiti  diversamente senza anche con una
borsa diversa
puoi immaginare è falso diventato reale e
reale diventa falso osiamo indossare e
indossare
oggi gridiamo all'altro e infrangiamo
le regole e creiamo nuove regole da
infrangere ok facciamolo nuovi errori possono
creare  nuovi sistemi nuove mentalità e
nuova moda creiamo questo ordine non
più Fashion Week quindi ok andiamo di
sicuro per questo ordine perché questo ordine
porta innovazione e ovviamente gli
esempi di nuovi tessuti di moda potrebbero
essere come cinque quinta stagione moda
abbigliamento sensibile al clima illusione
noi  'mascherano l'usura della forma o
vitamine e stimolanti nella fodera
mentre l'ape verrà assorbita attraverso la
pelle tutto questo potrebbe essere un orologio molto innovativo
tre capi e così via, quindi
puoi immaginare che questo capo sia il nuovo
Georgia Armani puoi immaginare questo
stilista che lavora per Chanel Chanel è morto
nel 71, quindi indossiamo già 40 anni di
design Shanell ma un'altra persona
forse questo potrebbe essere il nuovo affare in cui gli
uomini stanno bene  quindi dobbiamo andare
all'innovazione ed ecco Nick Cave un
artista che si sta godendo il
corpo godendosi la moda e quindi dice
prendiamo in giro così il futuro in cui
premoderno moderno postmoderno antimoderno si
mostra come un unico
disordine perfettamente organizzato  la nuova moda non è una
versione rivisitata della precedente l'
apocalisse è identica alla rivoluzione è
identica alla rivelazione quindi prima la nuova
pelle va bene può essere un nuovo linguaggio
del corpo la seconda pelle può essere una nuova identità
la terza pelle potrebbe essere una nuova Firenze nuova
tecnologia nuovi tessuti nuovi materiali e
istinto che useremo di più si
spera nuove visioni sarebbe un
paradiso grazie